el futuro de las pensiones es hoy uno de
los temas más candentes y que más
controversia genera son las pensiones
sostenibles que sistema de pensiones es
mejor el sistema de reparto de españa o
el sistema de capitalización de chile
precisamente en los últimos años las
protestas en chile han arreciado contra
un sistema de capitalización al que
muchos tachan de injusto ineficiente e
insolidario pero que hay de verdad en
todo esto
para contestar a estas incógnitas hoy
tenemos aquí en visual política a juan
ramón rallo uno de los mejores
economistas de españa colaborador
habitual en radio prensa y televisión y
director del instituto juan de mariana
pues bien vamos allá
[Aplausos]
[Música]
el modelo de pensiones chileno es
bastante diferente al modelo que
conocemos en españa se basa en un
sistema de capitalización que por lo
general suele explicar se bastante mal y
por tanto suele resultar bastante
controvertido para todos aquellos que lo
escuchan por primera vez es muy probable
de hecho que durante los últimos meses
hayáis visto que este sistema está
siendo objeto de feroces críticas por
parte de muchos de sus detractores
dentro y fuera de chile durante el año
2016 se han llevado a cabo numerosas
manifestaciones y protestas no siempre
pacíficas contra este modelo que algunos
han vendido como un éxito pero que a la
vista a la luz de estas protestas
parecería que es un rotundo fracaso está
siendo el paro nacional porque tengo
convencido que estamos con un sistema
previsional de facto para nuestro país
de facto para los trabajadores y
trabajadoras de chile y necesitamos un
nuevo sistema previsional para bien
antes de explorar más en detalle el
modelo chileno crecemos recordando que
existen dos modelos fundamentalmente
distintos para las pensiones el modelo
de reparto y el modelo de capitalización
los sistemas de reparto consisten
esencialmente en que a los trabajadores
de hoy se les quita una parte de su
salario presente para pagar las
pensiones de los jubilados también
hoy todo es una muy bonito todo suena
muy a solidaridad intergeneracional pero
eso funciona mientras la pirámide
poblacional adopte una forma adecuada si
la pirámide poblacional comienza a
invertirse de tal forma que cada vez hay
menos trabajadores por cada pensionista
entonces este modelo tan idílico tan
solidario empieza a flaquear lo vamos a
ver a lo largo del vídeo en el caso de
españa- pero ya os adelanto que el
resultado sobre todo a medio o largo
plazo no va a ser nada positivo
[Música]
por otro lado están los sistemas de
capitalización que consisten básicamente
en que los trabajadores cada trabajador
aporta una parte de su salario a una
cuenta de ahorro individual a una cuenta
de ahorros personalizada una especie de
hucha para cada trabajador donde los
ahorros se invierten y crecen cada año
también a través de la reinversión de
los rendimientos de esas inversiones
vamos metiendo euros dólares cada mes
los invertimos esas inversiones generan
renta y las rentas que generan esas
inversiones a su vez las re invertimos
otra vez en la hucha
[Música]
entre los modelos de pensiones que
podemos encontrar en el sistema chileno
es el que más se acerca al sistema de
capitalización ideal y también el más
exitoso pero entonces os preguntaréis
por qué recibe tantas críticas ha sido
realmente un fracaso un fiasco para
todos los ahorradores tal y como los
críticos afirman
uno de los argumentos clave contra el
modelo de capitalización el chileno es
ofrecer un dato que desde luego a simple
vista parece desolador y es que la
pensión media mensual en chile- en ese
modelo tan exitoso del que estamos
hablando apenas asciende a 282 euros es
decir menos de tres mil cuatrocientos
euros anuales y por tanto parece a
simple vista que se trata de una minucia
de un absoluto fracaso frente a las
pensiones que se pagan por ejemplo en
sistemas que pueden ser criticables como
el sistema de reparto español pero que
al final terminan ofreciendo pensiones
claramente superiores ahora bien lo
cierto y más allá de estas cifras que
ahora vamos a desgranar es que para
analizar el sistema de presiones chileno
hay que mirar un poco más en profundidad
y no dejarse llevar por las primeras
impresiones que desde luego lo
calificaría nos permitirían calificarlo
de un sistema que no permite pagar
pensiones muy abultadas primero es
verdad que las pensiones en españa son
como media cuatro veces superiores a las
pensiones medias de chile- y eso a pesar
de que la renta per cápita española sólo
es el doble que la chilena o dicho de
otra manera
sería relativamente justificable que las
versiones españolas fueran el doble que
las chilenas simplemente por el
diferencial de renta per cápita entre
países lo que no se justifica es que
sean cuatro veces más altas que las
chilenas por tanto tenemos que
inspeccionar más en detalle estos datos
y lo primero que hay que decir al
respecto es que hay que tener mucho
cuidado con esa aparente generosidad del
sistema público español de pensiones
porque como ahora vamos a comprobar se
trata de un espejismo que durante los
próximos años inevitablemente se va a
desmoronar por tanto podríamos estar
comparando un sistema de pensiones
sostenibles como el de chile con un
sistema de pensiones insostenible como
el español y por tanto evidentemente el
sistema insostenible de momento puede
pagar pensiones sustancialmente más
altas que el sistema sostenible
de hecho para darnos cuenta de esa
insostenibilidad tenemos que empezar
recordando que hoy en el momento en que
estás viendo este vídeo el sistema
público de pensiones español ya es
deficitario y es que en 2016
este déficit alcanzó la cifra de nada
menos que de 18 mil millones de euros
pero ahí no queda la cosa no este
agujero se va a ir incrementando década
tras década con el paso del tiempo
[Música]
por consiguiente no solo estamos
comparando un sistema como el chileno
que puede ser sostenible con uno como el
español que tiene problemas muy graves
de sostenibilidad sino que además esa
comparación resulta tramposa por los
elementos que no son homogéneos entre
ambos países y esos dos elementos no
homogéneos son los que aparentemente le
conceden a las presiones españolas una
mayor magnitud que las chilenas pero es
muy importante analizar cada una de
estas trampas para comprobar por qué el
sistema español no va a ser capaz de
pagar pensiones tan altas como las
actuales
[Música]
primera trampa una tasa de reemplazo
insostenible porque el actual sistema de
pensiones español es insostenible
empezamos hablando de la tasa de
reemplazo que va a ser el concepto clave
para entender esta insostenibilidad la
tasa de reemplazo atentos es el
porcentaje del último salario que un
jubilado percibe en forma de pensión
es decir si yo a los 64 años estoy
ganando 15 mil euros en un trabajo y me
jubilo con 7.500 euros de pensión la
tasa de reemplazo sería del 50 por
ciento es un concepto importante para
tener en cuenta cuál va a ser el salto
en el nivel de vida de los jubilados
cuando se jubilen porque si yo vengo
disfrutando de un salario de 15.000 y me
pasan de golpe a un salario de 7.500 o
tengo ahorros voy a tener que dar un
salto a la baja muy importante en mi
calidad de vida pues bien españa hoy en
día es el segundo país de la ocde con
una tasa de reemplazo más alta de las
pensiones públicas es decir es el
segundo país de la ocde donde las
pensiones públicas representan un mayor
porcentaje del último salario percibido
qué porcentaje pues a día de hoy en
torno al 80 por ciento
no del último salario sino del salario
medio que cobra un espanyol a lo largo
de toda su vida laboral en cambio en
chile esta tasa es del 40% es decir
prácticamente la mitad o justo la mitad
que en españa ahora bien como decía esta
alta tasa de reemplazo que sería
magnífica si se pudiese mantener en el
tiempo va a ser por desgracia
insostenible en el caso de españa hoy en
día españa cuenta casi con dos
trabajadores por pensionista y eso es lo
que permite sostener financiar esa alta
tasa de reemplazo insisto la segunda más
alta de toda la ocde pero por desgracia
la tendencia es a que esta tasa decrece
al largo del tiempo de hecho si miramos
las series demográficas del instituto
nacional de estadística o analizamos las
estimaciones que hacen organismos como
el gobierno o el fondo monetario
internacional o la ocde comprobaremos
que para el año 2050 se espera atención
que sólo haya un trabajador por cada
pensión que deba abonar el sistema y el
significado de esto es evidente si hoy
la tasa de reemplazo del 80 por ciento
de las pensiones se sustenta sobre 2
trabajadores por pensionista y vamos a
tener solo un trabajador por
pensionistas eso significa que el
hachazo a las pensiones públicas va a
tener que ser de órdago
[Música]
de hecho las previsiones que maneja el
propio gobierno de españa y que ha
remitido a la unión europea para
estudiar la sostenibilidad a largo plazo
del sistema de pensiones las
conclusiones son clarísimas y negrísimas
se estima que la tasa de reemplazo en
españa se irá reduciendo hasta situarse
por debajo del 50 por ciento en el año
2060 es decir pasaremos de un 80 por
ciento casi 80 por ciento de tasa de
reemplazo a menos del 50 por ciento y
además tengamos lo presente esta
previsión del gobierno que no es
precisamente halagüeña se basa en una
serie de estimaciones de pronóstico
sobre nuestro futuro que además son
bastante optimistas por ejemplo el
gobierno considera que en el año 2060
hemos hablando del año 2060 es decir no
son capaces de prever cuál va a ser la
tasa de paro dentro de 34 años pues
imaginémonos dentro de más de 40 años
pero bueno ya tiene el año 2060 el
gobierno espera que para que la tasa de
reemplazo sólo caiga por debajo del 50%
de los últimos salarios percibidos en
españa será necesario que esté
trabajando el 70
por ciento de la población en edad de
trabajar
[Música]
más
esto es un porcentaje más alto que en
ningún otro momento de nuestra historia
para que nos hagamos una idea en el
mejor momento de la historia económica
de este país o aparentemente el mejor
momento en el pico de la burbuja
inmobiliaria cuando la economía parecía
ir a todo tren y estábamos a los perros
con longanizas el porcentaje de
población en edad de trabajar que tenía
un empleo era sólo del 66% es decir el
gobierno necesita que en el año 2060 el
73 por ciento de las personas en edad de
trabajar tengan un empleo para que la
tasa de reemplazo de las pensiones sólo
caiga un 50 por ciento pero en el mejor
momento de nuestra historia solo trabajo
el 66 por ciento no 73 por tanto si en
lugar de llegar al 73 nos quedábamos en
el 66 o en el 65 la caída de la tasa de
reemplazo todavía sería mayor y con ello
las pensiones si la tasa de reemplazo
cae las pensiones también caen tal vez
por ello las propias comisiones obreras
no estamos citando tampoco fuentes muy
contrarias al sistema público de
pensiones el sindicato comisiones
obreras estima que en el año 2060 las
pensiones que podrá pagar el sistema de
seguridad social español hacen
se presentaran el 40 por ciento de los
salarios que ha percibido ese trabajador
durante su vida laboral y chad cuentas
el 80 por ciento hoy el 50 o 40 por
ciento en 2060 de que le suena una tasa
de reemplazo del 40 por ciento pues
justamente es la que hoy está pagando el
sistema chileno en chile la tasa de
reemplazo no se prevé que caiga a lo
largo de las próximas décadas porque el
sistema si es sostenible al basarse en
un sistema de ahorro personal el caso es
que si en españa hoy tuviésemos la tasa
de reemplazo que vamos a decir a lo
largo de las próximas décadas la pensión
media de españa sería de siete mil
setecientos euros anuales unos
seiscientos cincuenta euros al mes por
tanto poco más del doble de la que ya
está pagando hoy el sistema chileno bien
pongamos en perspectiva todo lo que
hemos visto hasta ahora al principio del
vídeo veíamos que la pensión media
española era cuatro veces superior a la
pensión media chilena a pesar de que el
nivel de renta en españa es sólo el
doble pues bien como hemos visto la
de reemplazo actual en españa es
insostenible por lo que en los próximos
años va a tener que reducirse
drásticamente y con ella las pensiones
al corregir esta tasa vemos que las
pensiones de españa y chile se ajustan y
finalmente su diferencia se explicará
sólo por el diferente nivel de riqueza
de cada país pero aquí todavía tenemos
que entrar en la segunda trampa que se
suele introducir en las comparaciones
entre españa y chile y es justamente que
el sistema público de pensiones español
es muchísimo más caro para un trabajador
que el sistema privado de pensiones
chileno pero cuanto más caro
[Música]
y segunda trampa unas cotizaciones
sociales altísimas bien en españa' las
cotizaciones a la seguridad social que
van a financiar las pensiones públicas
representan el 28 3% del salario bruto
de cada trabajador en chile en cambio es
sólo del 10% por tanto los chilenos
pagan cotizan ahorran para su jubilación
casi 3 veces menos que en españa y esta
es justamente la clave la tasa de
reemplazo de las pensiones en españa es
aproximadamente el doble que hoy en
chile pero las cotizaciones sociales son
el triple por tanto hoy en españa
pagamos el triple para recibir sólo el
doble y esto insisto es así con una tasa
de reemplazo del 80 por ciento pero ya
hemos visto ya hemos previsto cómo está
tasa de reemplazo va a terminar cayendo
a un porcentaje entre el 40 y el 50 por
ciento de los salarios en españa por
tanto a medio largo plazo los españoles
van a tener que pagar el triple van a
tener que ahorrar el triple se van a
tener que restringir el triple en su
consumo en su nivel de vida que los
chilenos para conseguir
nuevamente la misma pensión en términos
relativos que en chile es una trampa por
tanto donde está esa supuesta eficiencia
maravillosa esa magnífica solidaridad
intergeneracional del sistema público de
pensiones español frente al fiasco del
sistema privado de pensiones chileno en
ningún lado si los chilenos hubiesen
ingresado en el sistema de pensiones lo
mismo que un español a lo largo de su
vida laboral es decir si hubiesen
ahorrado mes a mes el 28 3 por ciento de
su salario hoy los chilenos contarían
con una tasa de reemplazo del 105 por
ciento es decir una persona un jubilado
se jubilaría con una pensión superior al
salario que ha percibido a lo largo de
su vida laboral por supuesto es verdad
los chilenos cuentan con la libertad si
así lo quisieran de ahorrar más del 10
por ciento de su salario cada mes para
la jubilación ese 10% es sólo el
porcentaje que el gobierno les obliga a
ahorrar
para prever una jubilación más o menos
adecuada y por tanto un chileno medio si
quiere una pensión más alta una pensión
que supere con creces la pensión
relativa del sistema público español
solo tiene que ahorrar lo mismo que se
ahorra forzosamente en el sistema
público español y así incluso con la
insostenible tasa de reemplazo actual en
chile se pagan pensiones relativamente
más altas que en españa
[Música]
así que si consideráis y ahora me dirijo
a vosotros amigos chilenos que
probablemente nos estáis escuchando que
las pensiones de vuestro modelo actual
son demasiado bajas que son
insuficientes es simplemente tenéis que
incrementar vuestra aportación al
sistema de ahorro privado al sistema de
ahorro personal por encima del 10% no
tenéis que copiar el sistema público de
pensiones español el sistema público de
pensiones español os obligará a ahorrar
el 30 por ciento no el 10 el 30% de
vuestro salario para recibir menos de lo
que estéis recibiendo ahora mismo y si
ya sé que muchos a lo mejor está
dispensando es imposible
en chile con los bajos salarios que se
perciben un trabajador ahorre el 30% de
su salario por tanto parecería que el
sistema privado de pensiones no ofrece
una solución para todos aquellos que no
tienen capacidad de ahorro pero no nos
confundamos el sistema público español
es exactamente igual en ese sentido en
españa si no ahorras el 30% de tu
salario si no cotizas a la seguridad
social por el 30% de tu salario tampoco
percibes pensión por tanto si
voluntariamente un chileno no es capaz
de ahorrar el 30 por ciento de su
salario porque cree que no va a llegar a
fin de mes qué sucederá si se le obliga
a ahorrar ese 30% no siendo capaz de
ahorrar lo de su salario percibido
mensualmente los puntos débiles del
sistema exigiendo por supuesto todo esto
no quiere decir que el sistema privado
de pensiones chileno sea perfecto y que
no necesite de cambios o de mejoras un
primer error por ejemplo fue de alguna
manera a lanzar políticamente el mensaje
a los chilenos que sólo ahorrando el 10%
que les obligaba a ahorrar el sector
público para sus cuentas de ahorro
personal accederían a pensiones que todo
el mundo considera dignas y suficientes
pues bueno quizá no tenía por qué ser
así
quizá el sector público no
haber vendido que solo con el 10% con
ese ahorro mínimo obligatorio se podía
acceder a pensiones adecuadas quizá
debería haber simplemente dejado a la
discrecionalidad de cada chileno que
determinara su tasa de ahorro en función
de la pensión a la que espera y desea
poder llegar a cobrar en el futuro y en
segundo lugar si le necesita mucha más
competencia entre sus fondos privados de
pensiones quizá por un asunto
esencialmente paternalista el estado
chileno ha restringido el número y el
tipo de fondos en los que los chilenos
pueden acumular su ahorro como
diciéndoles estos fondos son buenos
estos fondos tienen una marca de
garantía del estado podéis confiar en
ellos y por tanto ese 10% de ahorro
mensual obligatorio tenéis que destinar
lo también obligatoriamente a alguno de
estos fondos que cuentan con mi
aprobación problema de esto que este
espíritu paternalista del estado ha
terminado generando un oligopolio entre
los fondos privados de pensiones
chilenos porque el chileno no puede no
y no invertir en esos fondos sino
destinar esa porción de su salario
mensual a otro tipo de inversiones y eso
concede un poder de negociación alto
porque el estado obliga a que así sea a
esos fondos privilegiados con la
aprobación estatal porque no abrir mucho
más el sistema de la competencia porque
no permitir que cada chileno se
responsabilicen no solo de cuánto ahorra
cada mes sino de dónde invierte el
ahorro que ahorra cada mes en definitiva
amigos chilenos no os dejéis engañar por
cantos de sirena en tema de pensiones no
copies a españa un saludo a todos y
hasta la próxima
[Música]
[Aplausos]